hace al menos 12 mil 600 años grupos
indígenas de cazadores-recolectores
recorrieron américa hasta las
profundidades de la selva amazónica
prueba de ello son las miles de pinturas
rupestres distribuidas a lo largo de los
abrigos rocosos de la serranía la
lindoza y el parquet chiribiquete en el
nororiente de colombia ahora un polémico
descubrimiento ha puesto el foco
mediático sobre esta zona arqueológica
un equipo de investigadores colombo
británico anunció el descubrimiento de
nuevas pinturas rupestres que son objeto
de un documental televisivo para la
comunidad arqueológica colombiana los
artículos publicados en los medios
internacionales son imprecisos puesto
que no dan relevancia a los trabajos
realizados desde hace años en la lindoza
es muy cómodo para la comunidad también
científica colombiana
se ha esforzado y ha trabajado con las
uñas en investigar estos sitios que
llegue la prensa internacional
en una actitud casi que colonialista
dibuje
una universidad extranjera o a ciertas
personas como los descubridores de estos
sitios siendo que los verdaderos los
descubridores de estos sitios han sido
los locales y es que son las comunidades
locales como las de cerro azul que
también alberga pictografías milenarias
las que llevan años conservando el
territorio en un intento por atraer al
turismo a una región cargada de estigmas
por el conflicto de las guerrillas y el
narcotráfico vivo en este lugar hace 20
años aproximadamente nosotros vemos nos
hemos encargado de cuidar y proteger el
lugar porque para nadie un segmento de
este sitio estuvieron durante mucho
tiempo abandonados y se presentaba un
gran deterioro nosotros durante mucho
tiempo
hemos necesitado el apoyo del estado de
la gobernación nos ayudan mucho en el
tema de promoción del turismo pero sí
nos gustaría que nos apoyaran en temas
de infraestructura en el tema de las
vías para nosotros poder ofertar un
mejor turismo la preservación de un arte
que cuenta la historia de colombia a
través de imágenes que muestran animales
extintos
modos de lucha y convivencia de sus
primeros habitantes pasa por reconocer
el esfuerzo de estas comunidades